we knew Emperor Palpatine would be back
for months before the rise of Skywalker
ever hit theaters but we didn't know how
or why
now that the film is finally out we have
the answers to some of our questions but
it takes a little bit of consideration
to assemble that knowledge into a
clearer picture spoilers for rise of
Skywalker are of course ahead
the rise of Skywalker is a film was so
much going on that even with Palpatine
story at the core of it all viewers only
get pieces of the full picture it's not
totally clear how he returned after his
death in Return of the Jedi
when we first meet a began on X ago
Palpatine is alive but admits that he
has been dead before is somehow even
more decrepit appearance suggests that
he spent years hanging on to what little
life he has with the help of machines
it seems Palpatine owes a great deal of
his revival to the efforts of loyal
followers who became a cult of tsipras
errection as and on enacting his will
through any means necessary
Palpatine may have appeared as pure evil
to a great many people in the galaxy but
to others he was really their one true
leader thanks to them he was recovered
from the Death Star given some kind of
new life and brought to the legendary
Sith were in the build-up to the rise of
Skywalker's release fans posited
theories from cloning to the world
between worlds of star wars rebels as
possible explanations for Palpatine's
revival but we still have neither
confirmation or denial of any particular
method what we do know is that Palpatine
is constantly connected to a
life-support system that pumps various
liquids into and perhaps out of his body
this would suggest some kind of dark
scientific method of revival perhaps
similar to Darth Vader's life-support
system but it's also possible that's
only one part of a bigger picture it's
possible that other dark secrets from
Sith rituals to other pieces of magic
were used to jumpstart Palpatine's
livelihood again
Palpatine apparently didn't believe he
could simply announce that he'd returned
and retake his place at the top of the
pecking order
instead he needed a puppet to function
as a disruptor for the New Republic
enter Supreme Leader Snoke stretch
she must now change when he meets kylo
Ren Palpatine declares outright I made
snow and then provides evidence BIA a
tank full of discarded smoke bodies so
the supreme leader of the first order
was at some point engineered and created
by Palpatine himself to both serve as a
puppet leader and draw the darkness out
of Ben solo it worked because kylo Ren
did rise as a powerful follower of the
dark side
killing Snoke in the process after his
defeat at the Battle of Endor Palpatine
no longer wanted to simply rule the
galaxy he wanted to impose a sense of
fear on every single Star System he'd
need a whole fleet of planet-killers
Palpatine and his many followers
deployed their resources to create the
military machinery of the final order a
massive fleet of stardestroyers each
equipped with a planet killing cannon on
the underside we saw a miniaturized
Death Star tech deployed by the first
order in the last Jedi and in the rise
of Skywalker it becomes clear that
Palpatine and his followers have found a
way to make those tools even more deadly
after waiting for decades
Palpatine felt the time was right to
make his move with kylo Ren in place as
the first orders supreme leader
but Palpatine couldn't just leave his
life-support machinery in his fortress
on exha coal and perhaps he didn't want
to instead he sent a mysterious message
to the galaxy in which he vowed revenge
rumors of a resurrected Palpatine
quickly swirled terrifying the
resistance and enraging kylo ren rin
hunts down a sith wayfinder and seeks
out Palpatine on x ago Palpatine reveals
to him that he was the architect behind
Snoke and he's been the Darth Vader
voice in Ren's head he makes kylo Ren an
offer of control of the final order
fleet and leadership over a new empire
ren accepts the offer and agrees to
Palpatine's one condition that ren
tracked down and kill Rey to help
facilitate this Palpatine also provides
ren with a key piece of information that
helps explain why he wants her dead
ray is Palpatine's granddaughter and
therefore a major threat to his plans
for the return of the empire
palpatine soon begins reckoning with the
other potential threats to his plan a
spy within the first order later
revealed to be general Hux leaks
information about the final order fleet
to what's left of the resistance
commander poe dameron launches a covert
operation with the hope of stopping the
final orders launched before it starts
Palpatine has key allies in a position
to provide help to eliminate the spy in
the orders rise to power
Allegiant general pride has emerged as a
Palpatine loyalists who'd fought with
him in the Empire days bride kills
Huck's and assumes command of the final
order fleet Al Bateen commands bride to
show what the final order is capable of
by using a planet-killer cannon on the
planet could she me pose old stomping
grounds Alpha Team doesn't actually want
Rey dead instead wants to establish a
new empire with his granddaughter as
Empress after she kills him and absorbs
his force energy and as planned Ren
doesn't succeed in killing ray instead
he leads Rey right to Palpatine and Rey
discovers new layers of her own inner
darkness along the way what Palpatine
didn't factor into his plan was his
inability to fully draw Rey in or leia
organa sacrificing her own life and
force energy to help redeem her son with
rey resistance and the now redeemed Ben
solo ready to fight alongside her alpha
teen attempts to absorb all of the force
energy from both young Jedi to fully
resurrect himself it very nearly works
until Rey is able to call down the
spirits of the generations of Jedi
before her and kill Palpatine once and
for all
a masterfully crafted plan ultimately
fails because of kindness determination
and the Jedi legacy proves more powerful
than Palpatine's own dark blood it is
finished
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Star Wars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one